- Hey everyone, I hope you
are having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens.
I'm in Rio de Janeiro, Brazil,
and tonight for dinner,
we are going to a Brazilian
steakhouse barbecue
and this is gonna be my very first time
to ever go to a Brazilian steakhouse,
so I'm glad that my first
experience will be in Brazil.
There's a lot of culture that
surrounds Brazilian barbecue
and I know it's gonna
be all-you-can-eat meat
and the juices are gonna flow
and I know there's a
whole salad bar as well.
We're gonna find out and I'm gonna share
all the meat with you in this video.
(upbeat Latin style music)
(train roars)
- How are you, man?
- [Guilherme] Good, good,
welcome to Rio, man!
- [Mark] Thank you, thank you!
What's the name of the
restaurant that we're going to?
- [Guilherme] Churrascaria Palace.
- [Mark] Churrascaria Palace.
- Yeah, churrascaria means
steakhouse in Portuguese
and the name of the
churrascaria is palace.
- Awesome, and then we
decided to take the metro
because traffic is bad
and it was just one stop.
Get ready for some serious meat!
- [Guilherme] Yes.
- [Mark] We walked over to Copacabana,
the area of Copacabana,
and this is where the
steak is, the Churrascaria.
Oh man, I cannot wait to eat some meat.
(people chatter animatedly)
(piano plays loudly)
And already, it's pretty
full this evening,
but then yeah, the meat aroma
and then Guilherme has arranged a room
in the back here, I think.
So, it's quieter back here,
we're going to be able to film,
they're gonna come around with the meat.
Oh man, yeah, immediately
as you step in here,
you can smell the roasted
aroma of the meat.
We just met with Head Chef, Silva.
Head Chef Silva, right?
- [Silva] Yeah!
- [Mark] Head chef Silva is
bringing us into the kitchen,
to see where they're
grilling, roasting the meat.
- [Silva] Busy, busy.
- [Mark] Okay, great, great.
- [Silva] These are the grills.
(Mark laughs in awe)
(staff talk, plates rattle)
- [Mark] All of the meat are on spits.
They're all on stakes,
they're all rotating
and what's really interesting
are the different cuts of meat
which are different, specific to Brazil.
The different parts of
the meat that they use
and how they cut it and one of the,
I don't remember the name,
what's the cut of meat from the hump?
(Chef Silva talks in Portuguese)
- Cupim.
- Cupim, cupim.
This is from the hump of the--
- [Silva] Hump of the back.
- [Mark] This is one of the special meats.
- [Guilherme] When you
come to Brazil, eat cupim!
Cupim!
(Guilherme and Chef Silva
speak in Portuguese)
- Guilherme was telling
me that meat lovers,
they love it because of the mix of fat
and the flavor, the tenderness,
and so what they do, all of the meat
apart from the ribs, which are marinated,
I think most of the meat
is not really marinated,
but it's just salted, it's roasted
and then when they take it off the grill,
they use their knife and
just add a little bit
of that rock salt onto the meat
and then it goes back on the grill.
It's beef ribs?
- [Silva] Beef ribs.
(Mark laughs)
- The beef ribs cabinet. (laughs)
They are huge and they're
cooked for 12 hours.
- Two days marination.
- Two days marination and
then 12 hours cooking,
and you can see you can probably
just pull out that bone and
it would just slide out.
- He knows your channel.
- [Mark] How are you, man?
- He's saying "Nice to meet you."
- Nice to meet you!
(speaks in Portuguese)
- I cannot take the meat sweats
or my mouth watering any longer,
we're going back to the
table to start eating.
Obrigado.
- [Restaurant Staff] Obrigado, obrigado!
- You have the translation in English.
- [Mark] Cool.
So then this is coming for a churrascaria,
do you always have a buffet as well?
- Exactly.
- [Mark] With salad.
- With salad and it is good also,
heart of palms, artichokes,
oysters, salmon.
- Their condiment section
is out of control!
The dressings, the mustards,
the barbecue sauce, the ketchup.
Look at this selection of olive oils,
the sriracha, the chili
sauces, the Tabasco,
but then along with churrascaria,
along with your meat,
there's always a salad bar,
so there's vegetables,
there's different salads,
there's tomatoes, there's heart of palm,
there's some asparagus, and
there's even some seafood.
There's some oysters, there's
some squid and some stews.
It's good to balance meat with vegetables.
(upbeat Latin music)
(people chatter and laugh)
- So the first meat has arrived.
This is the hump, and
normally you can start
with the salad bar, but
that meat was too tempting,
we have to start immediately.
Chef Silva has brought it to our table
and so the custom practice
is you take the tongs, right?
And he slices off...
just look at it, it's flaking apart!
And then you grab it.
Oh, the steam.
Look at it, you can just see the strings
of that meat, the flakes of it. (laughs)
Oh wow!
Wow, that is amazing.
(upbeat Latin music)
- It's one of my favorite cut.
- [Mark] He knows it.
- It's amazing! (she and Mark laugh)
- [Mark] Oh the ribs, the beef ribs!
Oh my.
(people chatter and laugh)
Oh wow.
Oh my goodness.
(upbeat Latin music)
Obrigado.
It's just like, oh!
- [Chef Silva] Costela prime, prime rib.
- [Mark] Prime ribs.
Thank you, Guilherme.
- You're welcome.
(Mark laughs)
(they talk in Portuguese)
- [Mark] Obrigado, Chef Silva.
- [Waiter] Fried banana, french fries.
- That's unbelievable.
They just started coming around the meat,
coming around with the meat like a storm.
I don't even know how to react! (laughs)
It's just unbelievable.
He brought out the beef ribs.
The beef ribs are massive!
And you could just see
the meat wobbling around,
and he lifted the layer,
like the cap of fat,
he took out a slice of that meat,
and then his technique of
slicing it, of cutting it;
the tenderness just shines.
You can tell it's just
gonna melt in your mouth.
I haven't even tasted the meat,
but we already got three
types of their primest,
best, most well-known meats.
This is plate number one and
it just looks... (laughs)
it's just dripping with juices
and glistening with fat.
We should go back to that
first meat that he served,
which is the (stumbles over pronunciation)
- [Guilherme] Cupim.
- Cupim, cupim.
And you can see how this is
the layer that is roasted
and then underneath, that's the underside.
But yeah, you know I already said
it is just unbelievably good.
(people chatter and cutlery clinks)
Wow!
The mix of fat and it's almost so tender
it's almost like stringy,
it just strings apart.
And I love how the outer edge
is kind of crispy from being roasted,
but it's so soft and yeah,
that is pure wow meat.
You have to pace yourself
otherwise you can go crazy here.
- [Guilherme] We call
like an adult playground.
- [Mark] It is!
Okay, next up I gotta try the beef ribs.
Oh, man.
You definitely do not
need a knife for that.
- [Together] Cheers!
(Mark laughs)
The ribs are so, so tender and
so stringy and so flavorful.
This one is the sirloin, or the prime rib.
- [Guilherme] That's the prime rib.
- [Mark] Yeah.
(cutlery clinks)
(people chatter)
Oh wow!
That prime rib is unbelievable!
The juiciness, and I like my
meat rare so that is like,
like the pure saltiness of it.
Wow!
Oh, lamb, yes!
Obrigado.
Yeah, seriously, just after
being here for only 10 minutes,
the meat comes around so fast.
You can already tell you
just need to pace yourself
or you could just go meat crazy
and be stuffed in 30 minutes,
but you wanna pace
yourself, you wanna relax,
you wanna keep on eating
for as long as possible.
(people chatter and laugh)
Okay, got some chile;
some of the preserved
kind of pickled oiled chiles
to go with the meat next.
Let's try another bite of the,
let's go back to the hump.
And yeah, you don't even need a knife,
you can just fork cut it.
And then I'll try it with a
Scotch Bonnet chile on top.
As I was taking that bite,
it has a little heat to it,
he brought some of the
Carolina Reaper chile sauce.
We immediately have to
change our course of eating
and try some of the Carolina Reaper sauce.
Is that too much for one bite?
That's a good amount, let's try it!
Carolina Reaper sauce on, yes.
- [Man] Oh man, stoked.
- Oh, the flavor is amazing!
It's not too spicy,
but the flavor's like a,
it's like a very overly
pronounced Habanero.
Kind of like going up
your nose a little bit.
- That has some flavor to it, though,
that is some flavorful chile.
- You can feel the burn, but very good.
Obrigado.
This is one of the national
drinks of Brazil, a caipirinha.
Saúde.
It's sweet and sour and refreshing.
That does taste very good after a bunch
of Carolina Reaper chile sauce.
Oh, man!
That is, it's addictive spicy.
It's so good!
- [Guilherme] Okay, that's
the top sirloin steak.
- Top sirloin steak.
- Wow, look how that just comes away.
Oh yes.
(upbeat Latin music)
(Mark laughs)
Oh, it's too tender! (laughs)
We haven't even had the
chance to get salads
because the meat just comes
around and it's so good!
This one is the top sirloin.
And that fat cap is just unbelievable.
Look at that cut!
I just have to add a
little scoop of the Reaper.
(laughs)
That Carolina Reaper sauce,
it's addictive spicy!
Once you start eating it, you can't stop.
And that fat cap, it's melting,
it's melting on my tongue right now!
(Chef Silva speaks in Portuguese)
1985, Chef Silva.
He is a meat master.
He has been working
with meat, carving meat,
cooking meat, for over 35 years.
The beef shoulder.
Oh, the juiciness!
(laughs)
Oh, look at that.
Oh, wonderful.
Oh, the strings of that,
the grains of that,
the juiciness of that.
(laughs)
I just bit down and it squirted!
This shoulder is amazing.
This one is the lamb loin or something,
with that fat, that fat cap.
What another beauty.
It's kind of curled up a little bit.
That ratio of 50% fat!
That is so fatty
and so tender.
Okay, Chef Silva just brought around
the lamb chops with mint sauce.
Oh wow, the meat, it never stops,
but I am gonna take a break,
because I need to try the heart of palm
to break up the fatty meats.
This is the heart of palm.
Oh that just slices, it's
so soft, like cheese.
(upbeat Latin music)
Oh, that's wonderful!
It's kind of like bamboo shoot.
It's really juicy.
Okay, this one is the next,
the sweet palm.
(people chatter)
(upbeat Latin music)
Wow, that almost has a honey taste to it,
but again, it has that bamboo
shoot kind of consistency.
- [Guilherme] Another for you
- [Mark] Thank you.
- [Guilherme] You're welcome.
- Back to the meat and he just
served me an ostrich steak.
It's really lean!
It's similar to beef but even with
a more pronounced flavor to it.
And really lean and flavorful.
(people chatter)
(upbeat Latin music)
Chef Silva just does not, he
just does not let up on us.
He just keeps coming around
with the steaks of meat.
This one is like a veal steak.
I have not even seen the bottom
of my plate yet, this meal.
And again, that fat cap.
(laughs)
It's so juicy.
Look at that!
It's like a fat helmet on this piece.
- [Guilherme] Rafaela is
doing the Web checking.
Okay.
Wow!
That might be the juiciest piece yet.
- Everything you bring,
there's no way to refuse.
(meat sizzles)
- I'm starting to get a serious case
of the meat sweats.
And Chef Silva, he just does not let up.
No breaks for Chef Silva.
The meat is flowing and we
have not repeated anything.
Thank you.
This is Chef Silva's creation.
It's the chorizo meat and
then also another type,
but that is juicy and he
cooked it on that hot plate.
It's hot, fresh, extraordinary juicy.
Wow!
The difference is it's more
firm, but it's so juicy.
I almost forgot about the
lamb ribs, lamb chops.
Whoa!
I think I just got an entire
cap of fat in that bite.
Oh, salad!
Time for some vegetables.
This is the owner's salad
that Guilherme ordered.
There's lettuce, there's
tomatoes, there's onions.
Oh, those tomatoes in that salad
taste extra good right
now, after that much meat.
- [Group] Saude!
- [Guilherme] Chin chin!
- Oh, that's refreshing!
(Guilherme speaks in Portuguese)
We are definitely slowing down.
The meat, the meat is hitting us hard,
but he came around with a skewer.
This is a fresh water Amazon fish,
which, yeah, we gotta try.
- Pirarucu.
- Pirarucu?
- It's so firm, it's almost like chicken.
Really good.
I got the ribs of the fish.
(Guilherme and Chef Silva
speak in Portuguese)
Also Amazon fish.
Then we've got one more; this
is the last of the meats.
And this is another Amazon
fish, the ribs of the fish.
Chef Silva, the man, the hero.
The hero of the night.
This is a serious protein overdose.
It could be the jet lag,
could be the caprinha,
could be just the straight up meat sweats,
but I don't know if I can get
off this sofa seat right now.
Physically, physically I
don't think I can. (laughs)
That's great.
Wow.
I am almost to the brim
with meat right now.
Chef Silva insisted that we have the ribs.
These are straight fish ribs.
It looks like a pork rib, but it's fish.
And that literally is like the
texture of pork and chicken.
Wow!
That's crazy and amazing.
You would not believe that's fish.
Yeah, that's like straight chicken.
Like chicken ribs.
Chef Silva, what a man.
What a man.
What a chef.
The hero, the hero of the night.
Chef Silva
- Thank you very much.
- He took care of us; his service,
and the way he served us
and carved us the meat,
that was phenomenal!
- Thank you.
Obrigado.
We've moved on to dessert.
This is one of their house desserts.
It's called Cat's Egg.
It's ice cream with a
variety of different,
oh thank you, a variety
of different chocolates
and then you drizzle it on.
Obrigado.
- [Guilherme] That's their creation.
- Whoa!
Oh, that chocolate sauce!
I'm not that huge on desserts,
but after eating that much salty meat,
a few bites of sweet dessert
tastes really good, actually.
And that completes this churrascaria,
Brazilian steakhouse barbecue experience.
Man, at this stage,
what's up man?
- [Man] Obrigado.
- Obrigado.
At this stage in the Brazilian
steakhouse experience,
it's just hard to walk,
it's hard to think.
It's, wow!
That was a meat experience of your dreams!
Obrigado.
You know that feeling of
coming out of a movie theater,
like after you've been sitting
in a theater for three hours?
That's like the exact same
feeling I'm getting right now.
It's like a different world out here.
(laughs)
That really was the Brazilian
meat of your dreams.
That was like every dream,
every thought I had about Brazilian meat
is now in my stomach.
My first time to have a
Brazilian steakhouse experience,
and yeah, that exceeded my expectations.
The different cuts of meat;
everything was different!
Everything tasted different.
The textures, the varieties,
the different wellnesses of the meat.
Huge thank you to
Guilherme and to Rafaela.
And, by the way, Guilherme,
he was also making a video,
Rio For Fun, Rio For Food;
I'll have his links in
the description box below.
That was so much fun to hang out.
It's such a social,
one tip is that you want to pace yourself.
Don't take too much meat too fast at once
or you will just be stuffed in 10 minutes,
'cause the meat, it just doesn't stop.
Okay, that was an
amazing, an amazing meal.
I want to say a big thank
you for watching this video,
and if you're not already
subscribed, be sure to subscribe.
I'm gonna be publishing
an entire huge series
of Brazil food from around the country.
We're gonna be traveling
around the entire country,
so be sure to check out
all of the other videos
in this Brazilian food tour series.
Thanks again for watching.
Goodbye from Rio de Janeiro, goodnight!
See you on the next video!